LAURA INGRAHAM LIVE NOW!
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M JESSE WATERS IN FOR LAURA
INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM NEW YORK.
THANKS FOR WATCHING THE SPECIAL
"THE TRUMP AGENDA IN 2018."
THAT AGENDA GOT A HUGE START
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SIGNED THE
TAX CUT LAW INTO LAW THIS
MORNING.
>> WE HAD THE LARGEST TAX CUTS
FORMAL SIGNING IN EARLY JANUARY,
BUT I WATCHED THE NEWS THIS
MORNING AND THEY ALL SAID WILL
HE KEEP HIS PROMISE?
WILL HE SIGN IT BY CHRISTMAS?
IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU WITH
US.
WE WILL SIGN THIS RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS SOMETHING I'M VERY PROUD
OF.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> LOOKING FORWARD TO 2018, THE
TAX CUT COULD BE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE MAKER.
RIGHT NOW DEMOCRATS THINK
THEY'RE POISED FOR BIG GAINS IN
THE MID-TERMS ELECTIONS BECAUSE
OF POLLS SHOWING UNPOPULARITY OF
THE.
AND THE TAX CUT.
BUT IF THOSE CUTS MAKE AN
ALREADY HUMMING ECONOMY REALLY
TAKE OFF, THE PRESIDENT AND THE
GOP WILL BE IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT
COME NOVEMBER.
HE REVEALED ONE OF HIS TOP
PRIORITIES FOR EARLY 2018 BEFORE
HEADING TO MAR-A-LARGO FOR THE
CHRISTMAS BREAK.
>> I REALLY DO BELIEVE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
BIPARTISAN WORK DONE AND MAYBE
WE START WITH INFRASTRUCTURE.
BECAUSE I REALLY BELIEVE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE
BIPARTISAN.
WE HAVE SPENT $7 TRILLION IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
NOT TO MENTION ALL OF THE LIVES
AND THE HEART ACHE.
IT'S SO SAD.
$7 TRILLION.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO REBUILD OUR
COUNTRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT MAY TIMELY GET
THAT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IT WOULD SEEM DIFFICULT FOR
DEMOCRATS OF ALL PEOPLE TO ARGUE
ABOUT MORE DOMESTIC SPENDING.
SO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT.
LET'S BRING IN OUR GUESTS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER
ADVISER OF THE PRESIDENT,
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA IS IN
WASHINGTON.
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY, LEO
TERRELL IS IN LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA.
SO DOCTOR, I'LL START WITH YOU.
TRUMP WILL HAVE TO RUN ALONG
WITH HIS ALLIES IN CONGRESS ON
REALITY.
THEY CAN POINT TO PEOPLE'S BANK
ACCOUNTS AND SAY THERE, THAT'S
THE TAX CUT.
DEMOCRATS, ON THE OTHER HAND,
ARE RUNNING ON EMOTION AND ENVY.
THEY'RE SAYING THE RICH ARE BAD
AND YOU'RE GETTING HOSED.
YOU THINK IT WILL BE HARD FOR
THE REPUBLICANS TO OUTMESSAGE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, FIRST
OF ALL AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE SPEECH YOU GAVE AT TURNING
POINT YESTERDAY.
>> THANKS VERY MUCH.
>> QUITE A SPEECH.
>> FLATTERY WILL GET YOU
EVERYWHERE, DOCTOR.
>> I TRY.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
RUN ON?
WE HAVE 3% GDP GROWTH RATES
ALREADY, 1.5 MILLION JOBS
CREATED.
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN 17
GET A TAX CUT.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO RUN ON?
I DON'T SEE THE MESSAGE.
LET'S REMIND OURSELVES, JESSE,
WHO NEVER REACHED 3% GDP GROWTH
RATE FOR ONE YEAR FOR HIS WHOLE
EIGHT YEARS IN OFFICE.
2018 WILL BE INCREDIBLE FOR THE
PRESIDENT, IT'S GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLE FOR ALL AMERICANS
WHETHER YOU VOTED FOR HIM OR
>> SO LEO, THE POINT IS, THE
THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE TAX
CUTS.
THEY'VE BEEN AGAINST EVERYTHING
ALONG, THEY CAN'T CLAIM ANY
CREDIT.
IS THAT GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
>> YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO WIN
THIS ARGUMENT BY USING
REPUBLICAN PRINCIPLES.
TODAY WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
THE BUS.
THEY'RE THE REASON WHY
REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST THIS
BILL.
CALIFORNIA WILL BE DOUBLE TAXED.
NOW THEY'LL HAVE THE
LOCAL TAX.
THEY HAVE WIPED OUT THE INTEREST
DEDUCTION ON MORTGAGE.
LET ME TELL YOU HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS.
ISSA SAYS THIS BILL IS NOT GOOD.
HOUSE.
YOU'RE UNPOPULAR.
RIGHT NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD
NOT SELL FREE GROCERIES TO THE
YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT ABOUT THE
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA PEOPLE.
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GET
HAMMERED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS,
AT&T ANNOUNCING, COMCAST
ANNOUNCING.
THEY'RE SHOWERS WORKING,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS, WITH
$1,000 CHRISTMAS CHECKS AS A
RESULT OF THE TAX CUT,
DR. GORKA.
>> I KNOW YOUR GUEST LIKE
AUTOCRATIC PRESIDENTS LIKE
OBAMA.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T HELP IT IF
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK OR
CONNECTICUT IS HOSING THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE THERE.
THAT'S THE STATE'S DECISION TO
DO SO.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT IN NEW YORK
AND CONNECTICUT, YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AS A VOTER.
WAS IN NEVADA THIS WEEK.
I WAS STOMPING FOR DANNY
TARKANIAN.
HEADQUARTERS.
FORKLIFT TRUCKS.
LAST YEAR, EACH OF THESE COST
$200,000.
LAST YEAR THEY SOLD 115.
JESSE, THANKS TO DONALD TRUMP,
THAT IS THE TRUMP EFFECT.
>> LET ME JUST -- DR. GORKA,
ANSWER THESE TWO QUESTIONS.
FUNDAMENTAL AMERICAN PRINCIPLE.
TO BE A HOMEOWNER, TO BUY A
HOME.
EVERY AMERICAN HOMEOWNER GOT
HOSED BECAUSE THE INTEREST
DEDUCTION ON MORTGAGE RATES HAVE
BEEN ELIMINATED.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE OLD TRADITIONAL FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE?
SPENDING CUTS WITH TAX CUTS.
WHERE IS PAUL RYAN'S VIDEO?
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE GOING TO
FORGET ABOUT SPENDING CUTS?
THIS TAX BILL ADDS $1.5 TRILLION
TO THE DEFICIT.
WHERE IS THE FISCAL CONSERVE
TIFF REPUBLICANS --
>> GORKA, YOU WANT TO TAKE
THIS -- I'LL TAKE HALF OF IT.
ON THE AGENDA IN 2018, THEY WANT
A WELFARE REFORM WILL GET DONE
WHICH WILL CUT SPENDING AND
PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING MASSIVE
GOVERNMENT.
DR. GORKA, YOU WANT TO FINISH
OFF THAT POINT?
>> SUDDENLY THE LEFT IS WORRIED
ABOUT SPENDING?
PRESIDENT OBAMA DOUBLED THE
MONEY OWED IN COMPARISON TO ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT BEFORE HIM.
SUDDENLY THEY CARE ABOUT HOW
LET'S BE SERIOUS.
>> DR. LEO, YOU'RE USING SO MANY
PARTY.
>> I'M JUST SHOWING THE
HYPOCRISY ABOUT WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING, THIS IS
SO UNLIKE REPUBLICANS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, TRUMP HAS JUST
SIGNED THE EXECUTION WARRANT FOR
EVERY BLUE STATE CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICAN.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
LIKE KARL ROVE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR SAID --
>> KARL ROVE IS HISTORY.
>> NOW HE HAS NO CREDIBILITY.
>> HE'S A RHINO.
>> DR. GORKA --
>> HE'S A RHINO?
>> NAME CALLING.
SHAME ON YOU.
>> LET'S LAY OFF OUR OWN
CONTRIBUTORS FOR A SECOND.
THE HOUSE IS UNDER SIEGE.
HISTORICALLY IT FLIPS WHEN THE
CASH ON HAND.
THE RNC HAS ABOUT $45 MILLION
THEY HAVE TO FUND RAISE MORE IF
THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING TO WIN
BACK ANYTHING.
>> LET ME HIT THAT OUT OF THE
PARK.
IN ALABAMA, IN DECEMBER, GUESS
WHAT?
MORE DEMOCRATS CAME OUT IN
STORM IN 2018.
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE OVER THE
MID-TERM ELECTION.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE UPSET
WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
CAN'T SELL GROCERIES, CAN'T SELL
FREE GROCERIES BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT?
HE'S ALIENATED THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WITH HIS RHETORIC.
>> DR. GORKA, GO AHEAD.
>> THE ONLY PEOPLE UPSET WITH
THIS PRESIDENT ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
AMERICA CHOSE HIM ON NOVEMBER 8
AND WHO KNOW THAT IF THIS
ECONOMY KEEPS ON TRUCKING, THAT
THEY'RE IN TROUBLE.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS NOW
IT'S PREDICATED ON THIS
PRESIDENT FAILING AND ON THIS
ECONOMY FAILING.
TAX BREAKS, TO WISH THAT YOU
EVERYBODY'S BOAT CAN RISE.
EVERYBODY'S BOAT CAN FLOAT.
BUT NO, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
VOTE FOR THE OTHER PERSON LOSING
MONEY.
>> YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT THOSE
BONUSES.
THOSE -- WE WERE PROMISED JOBS,
NOT BONUSES.
BONUSES ARE ONE-TIME GIVE-AWAYS.
>> WHAT ABOUT JOBS?
WE BROUGHT MILLIONS.
>> THERE'S BEEN 2 MILLION JOBS
CREATED SINCE THE PRESIDENT CAME
INTO OFFICE.
WAGES WILL GO UP AS A RESULT OF
THIS AND JOBS.
THE THING HASN'T EVEN KICKED IN
YET.
ARE YOU WILLING TO GIVE IT A
CHANCE?
>> MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE,
MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE IN
LESS THAN A YEAR HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OFF FOOD STAMPS.
HOW CAN YOU NOT BE THANKFUL THAT
THAT IS HAPPENING?
>> OKAY.
YOU'RE CHANGING THE SUBJECT.
I WANT TO STICK --
>> YOU SAY JOBS.
BUY BACK THEIR STOCK.
IT'S TO THEIR INCENTIVE TO BUY
BACK THEIR STOCKS.
THE EXECUTIVES WILL GET HUGE
I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, YOU
CAN'T GUARANTEE --
>> LEO, YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE THAT
CAN COMPLAIN ABOUT AMERICAN
WORKERS GETTING $1,000 BONUS
CHECKS.
HOW IS THAT A BAD THING?
WHY CAN'T YOU SAY IT'S GOOD?
>> I WANT JOBS.
I DON'T WANT TIP MONEY.
I WANT A JOB.
>> OKAY.
>> I WANT A JOB.
PROMISED JOBS.
>> LEO, YOU MUST BE LIVING
LARGE.
I NEVER TIPPED A G.
>> YOU HAVE TO LIVE IN THE REAL
WORLD.
I'M SORRY.
>> LET'S NOT CONFUSE A BONUS
WITH A JOB.
>> I THINK LET'S SEE HOW IT
PLAYS OUTS.
LEO, TIPPING $1,000?
I NEED TO COME WORK FOR YOU.
>> BRING ME BACK IN 12 MONTHS